♪ ♪
I almost... I know.
I can't, uh...
(sighs)
That's right!
I still haven't...
Well, you get it.
It's the name of the segment.
Um...
And today was a big day for us
in the "not forgetting about
mother(bleep)ers" community.
Bill Cosby will stand trial
for sexual assault
in Pennsylvania, as today's
preliminary hearing wraps up
in the single criminal case
lodged against Cosby
amid dozens of accusations
of sexual assault and rape.
Yep! Fat, Perverted Albert's
going to court, you guys.
Man, this is gonna be
the most watched trial
of a once-beloved
black celebrity since...
Yeah, I can't really think
of one.
Coming up blank.
Wait, you know what,
whenever, uh... whenever I draw
a blank like this,
I pour myself...
(cheering and applause)
I pour myself a glass of O.J.,
just to help me to remember,
okay?
Okay. Who's another
once-beloved... (laughs)
black celebrity to fall
in disgrace like this? Mmm.
Mmm. Nope. O.J. didn't do it.
I don't know. Mm-mm. There.
I don't know. Mm.
(chuckles)
So sad. Some people were like,
"That's right, Larry.
He didn't do it."
No. I was talking about the...
Okay, so what was this hearing
about?
REPORTER: Prosecutors claim the
2004 encounter between Cosby
and then-Temple University
employee Andrea Constand
was criminal sexual assault.
Okay, now, look, we talk a lot
about the failings
of the criminal justice system
here, but, honestly,
Bill Cosby going to trial?
That's a huge victory.
There are so many women
who have come forward
whose voices
were never listened to.
And if he gets to experience
even a small fraction
of the humiliation these women
did, I will be happy.
I know
it's a little Schadenfreude,
but I will be happy.
I will also be happy hearing
the court reporter attempting to
read back some Cosby statements.
(mimicking Cosby sounds)
"Okay, the defense rests.
We're doing great."
And, by the way, guys,
he's once again pulling out
the old Mr. Magoo defense.
REPORTER: We see
he's making his way there
through the-the security,
the metal detector.
-He looked like he had a bit
of a... bit of an issue -Yeah.
going through there.
You got to be (bleep) me.
That (bleep) can see, man.
Come on. He can see! He can see!
Trust me on this! Trust me.
Show that again, Dre!
Show it again.
Show it again. Look, watch,
he's gonna pull back
right before he hits it. Watch.
(stammers)
See?
Even Stevie Wonder pretends
he's blind better than that,
-you guys.
-(groaning)
Oh, you think he's blind?
Okay. All right.
I know Stevie Wonder's blind,
okay?
Well, if we can't lock up Cosby
behind bars,
at least we got him
to walk into one. Fine.
But, believe it or not, there
are still people out there
who think
Cosby might be innocent.
All right. So how's that gonna
go after today?
REPORTER: A 2005 deposition
from the Constand case
reveals a cavalier Cosby.
When asked a graphic question
about a sexual encounter
with another woman,
a young model, and the manner
in which she pleased him,
the comedian answered, "Bingo."
Great. Now that asshole's
ruined bingo for me.
If you're gonna bring up
a board game,
why not Monopoly
and just go directly to jail?
How 'bout that?
(sighs) All right. What else
from Leonard Part Sick?
Bill Cosby admitted to quite
a bit in 2005 and 2006
during depositions
for his civil trial.
Uh, he described
giving quaaludes and alcohol
to numerous women
before having sex with them.
And on the night in question
in this case, he said...
REPORTER (reading):
-(audience groaning)
-WOMAN: What?!
(sighs heavily)
You know what I call the area
between permission
and rejection? Rape.
-(laughter and groaning)
-All right?
And, Cosby,
if you're really so cavalier
about the women
whose dignity you robbed,
then you should be somewhere
between a maximum security
prison and hell.
Bingo, mother (bleep).
We'll be right back.
(cheers and applause)